Trevor thanks for joining us when this
idea come to you they came about on
Thursday actually David Carr Peter what
my good buddies tweeted out asking if we
get a Sandlot game together to add a
little bit of baseball while the seasons
been shut down so talk to my oh my guys
over here momentum we decided that we
could make that happen so we spent the
next 36 hours running around like crazy
and put on a little ball event and it
was kind of eerie playing in front of no
fans I've never done that before and
that's kind of what we're trying to
support here is you know the people that
go on notice that make the game possible
people that work session stands and
ushers and all that different stuff how
concerned are you about the corona virus
I don't know I don't know if I should be
concerned or not like I don't know that
I think that's what the biggest issue is
no one really knows what's going on I
haven't been affected by it personally
yet so it's hard for me to say I know
obviously a lot of people have and it's
very serious time so I'm trying to take
as much precaution as possible I just
don't I don't know are you able to get
are you guys working out in Arizona so
our facility was closed this past
weekend for a deep-clean and
sanitization I'm saying that right so I
have some some dumbbells that I got I've
been doing some stuff at home I'm going
to find a place to to work out moving
forward I got to stay in shape obviously
but know no one's been working out
recently any idea of when the projected
date for the season to start is yeah May
11th I think is the earliest that will
start now with the eight-day week
postponement that they announced
yesterday the day before I don't see it
happening but on that date I gotta
imagine it's going to be June at least
and that's just my personal speculation
I don't have any inside info but I just
don't see any way it happens before June
1st and that's being pretty aggressive
are you gonna have more wiffle ball
games how do you plan on raising 1
million
now so I mean now with the CDC
guidelines and having less than you know
ten people or less
meeting spaces it's tough it's tough to
do anything like that we're just trying
to get the word out as much as possible
I realize that it's tough times for
everybody and there's a lot of people
not just the stadium workers there's a
lot of people in baseball and outside of
baseball that are struggling right now
and they're unsure so I know it's a big
ask to have people donate right now but
if there's anyone that can find it in
their budget it's it would help a lot of
people can you give that address of if I
saw where Jerry Seinfeld sent a video he
wrote Trevor Bauer to the rescue love
this guy so Seinfeld sent out a tweet on
Friday
what's the address if people want to go
and donate yeah so fun GoFundMe you can
look it up there or you can go to my
Twitter account that's the pin tweet on
my Twitter account a power outage on
Twitter
you've been busy though here in the
offseason I know that you had some
things to say about the Astros in the
commissioner Rob Manfred you've got a
chance to sit down with the commissioner
what did you guys discuss baseball
industry in general I don't want to
speak too specifically on what was
discussed but I thought a little good
conversation I think he was candid and
honest and you know genuinely curious to
hear what I had to say and I was
genuinely curious to see how he thought
about things and what he had to say I'm
not sure any resolution was necessarily
come to but I think we understood each
other at least yeah I knew you were
critical to playoff expansion proposal
certainly critical of the Astros and
then you were showing batter's what
pitches were coming with glove movements
in spring training to issues I can't go
into the story like I promised the guy
involved and I wouldn't but it was a
back story of a buddy of mine and just
joking around having some fun oh so
showing the batter's what was coming
there's a back story to them yeah yeah I
called that baby the hitter and let him
know it was nothing personal or try to
shut him off
just you know it's pretty training is
it's fun for a lot of reasons so I was
just trying to have some fun with some
friends of mine and does this help or
hurt the Astros with this separation
before the start of the season yeah I
guess I can't see a way that it helps
anybody but just know there was so much
vitriol build-up with these guys and
they were unapologetic didn't take any
blame guys were getting hit during
spring training and it felt like there
was gonna be some momentum or movement
going into the regular season where you
know these fans were not gonna let the
Astros forget about it
now gotta wait a couple of months and I
wonder what that climates gonna be like
for the Astros when they start to play
games I can imagine will be the same
fans baseball fans are very good at
having long-term memories it's part of
the sport with the most history and the
most stats behind it and all that and
fans don't forget too easily so I got
imagine it'll be it'll be somewhat the
same I just hope that we get baseball
back in in a short order you should show
up at a batting cage and just start
throwing like a little little leaguers
in there and just you know do it do a
video I would see the CDC ten people are
less right now anyway is something I
have considered I'd like to get more
fans involved and interact with the kids
and stuff like that but you know what
ten people are less it's hard to it's
hard to come up with any ideas like that
right now well congrats on what you're
trying to do for the Reg Stadium workers
and the go fund me page with Trevor
Bauer Trevor good luck I don't know what
you do in your downtime what do you do
all day so I have my media company
momentum and we're pumping out a bunch
of content with different players that
we've worked with this spring and I'm my
own personal YouTube channel it's Trevor
Bauer on YouTube and posting daily vlogs
about what's going on right now and my
my life and what I'm doing in this time
got a lot of content coming out I do
tips with Trevor on Tuesdays to give
young baseball players tips for training
and whatnot
I'm a fan questions segment on Fridays
and I have a new series coming out
called breaking point where we got your
games that I've been all
to break down what I was thinking in the
moment and what I was trying to do what
actually happens I got about two young
lucky you know all that different stuff
so good pumping out a bunch of content
for the fans Trevor thank you we
appreciate your time
good luck thank you for having me on
that's Trevor Bauer Reds pitcher